I write about food for the economist and
these books will make you a better cook
this is probably Italy's best-selling
cookbook it will guide you through
everything from tiramisu to Fresh
tortellini sichuanese Cuisine is among
the world's most complex and delicious
this book is a lovely portrait of the
region and A brilliantly Accessible
guide to its cooking this contains the
single best instructions anywhere for
making rice with accessible non-bank
breaking recipes this beautifully
written book highlights how Central
African Americans have been in shaping
American Cuisine the author was the
first black woman to edit a major
newspaper's food section these two
volumes distill classical French cuisine
making it accessible to the home cook
this book is vegetable Centric but not
wholly vegetarian it puts taste before
virtue and will make you a better
seasonal Shopper and cook this is as
much an ethnography of the Jewish
diaspora as it is a cookbook and it
reveals how profoundly culture place and
Cuisine shape each other